da ist ein weg
[Musik]
warum werden diese fahrräder eigentlich
nicht mehr gebaut räder werden nicht
mehr gebaut weil es die firma nicht mehr
aber diese klopp rede war noch sehr
billig ja in der ddr aber nach der wende
wurden viele firmen der ehemaligen ddr
geschlossen
das bedeutet finde so nennt man die zeit
der wiedervereinigung
es war die zeit als aus ostdeutschland
und westdeutschland ein land wurde okay
aber warum mussten diese firmen schließt
und das verstehe ich nicht
ostdeutschland und westdeutschland waren
nicht nur geteilt es waren zwei total
unterschiedliche länder mit völlig
verschiedenen politischen system und
unterschiedliche währungen und die
menschen in der ddr konnten nicht so
einfach ihre verwandten oder freunde im
westen besuchen oder in andere westliche
länder reisen so wie heute
das weiß ich ja alles und irgendwann
hatten viele ostdeutsche genug von der
ddr und haben für mehr freiheit
demonstriert und als die grenze dann
endlich weg war
da gab es viele produkte aus der
ehemaligen ddr auch nicht mehr
aber die produkte war nicht schlecht
aber die menschen leute neben
veränderungen
so und jetzt bringen wir das rad mal
wieder so richtig auf vordermann
[Musik]